>> AND, YOU AND I HAVE HAD A
NUMBER OF CANDID AND USEFUL
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE YEARS
AND SINCE I HAVE BECAME
PRESIDENT AS WELL.
YOU ARE KIND ENOUGH TO CALL ME
TO CONGRATULATE ME AND I'M KIND
ENOUGH TO CONGRATULATE YOU AS
WELL.
THERE IS LITTLE SUBSTITUTE FOR
FACE TO FACE DISCUSSIONS, AND
AS YOU KNOW I AM COMMITTED TO
KEEPING THE LINES OF
COMMUNICATIONS OPEN BETWEEN YOU
AND ME PERSONALLY, BUT OUR
GOVERNMENTS ACROSS THE BOARD
BECAUSE OUR TWO COUNTRIES HAVE
SO MUCH THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DEAL WITH.
AS THE LEADERS OF TWO NATIONS,
WE SHARE RESPONSIBILITY TO SHOW
THAT CHINA AND THE UNITED
STATES CAN MANAGE OUR
DIFFERENCES, PREVENT
COMPETITION FROM BECOMING
ANYTHING FROM NEAR CONFLICT,
AND TO FIND WAYS TO WORK
TOGETHER AND URGED GLOBAL
ISSUES THAT REQUIRE OUR MUTUAL
COOPERATION.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS CRITICAL
FOR THE SAKE OF OUR TWO
COUNTRIES AND THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A KEY TO THE THEME OF
THE COP27 MEETING, WHERE I
SPOKE ON FRIDAY AND WE'LL BE
DISCUSSING A LOT OF THESE
CHALLENGES TOGETHER.
I HOPE OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
HOURS.
THE WORLD EXPECTS, I BELIEVE,
CHINA AND THE UNITED STATES TO
PLAY KEY ROLES IN ADDRESSING
GLOBAL CHALLENGES FROM CLIMATE
CHANGES, TO FOOD INSECURITY,
AND FOR US TO BE ABLE TO WORK
TOGETHER.
THE UNITED STATES STANDS READY
TO DO JUST THAT, TO WORK WITH
YOU IF THAT IS WHAT YOU DESIRE.
SO PRESIDENT XI, I CAN LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR ONGOING --
AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
>> MISTER PRESIDENT, IT IS GOOD
TO SEE YOU >> TRANSLATOR: THE
LAST TIME WE MET WAS IN 2017,
DURING THE WORLD ECONOMIC FORUM
IN DAVOS.
THAT WAS ALREADY MORE THAN FIVE
YEARS AGO.
SINCE YOU HAVE ASSUMED THE
PRESIDENCY, WE HAVE MAINTAINED
COMMUNICATION VIA MEDIA
CONFERENCES, PHONE CALLS, AND
LETTERS.
BUT NONE OF THEM CAN REALLY
SUBSTITUTE FOR FACE TO FACE
EXCHANGES.
AND TODAY, WE FINALLY HAVE THIS
FACE TO FACE MEETING.
FROM THE INITIAL CONTACTS AND
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONS AND TODAY, CHINA AND
THE UNITED STATES HAVE GONE
THROUGH 50 PLUS EVENTFUL EARS.
WE HAVE GAINED EXPERIENCE AND
WE HAVE ALSO LEARNED LESSONS.
HISTORY IS THE BEST TEXTBOOK SO
WE SHOULD TAKE HISTORY AS A
MIRROR AND LET IT GUIDE THE
FUTURE.
CURRENTLY, THE CHINA U.S.
RELATIONS SHE IS FACING A LOT
OF --
IT IN SUCH A CONCERN.
WE ALL CARE A LOT ABOUT IT.
THIS IS NOT THE FUNDAMENTAL
INTEREST OF OUR TWO COUNTRIES
AND PEOPLES, AND IT IS NOT WHAT
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY
EXPECTS OF US.
AS LEADERS OF THE TWO MAJOR
COUNTRIES, WE NEED TO CHARGE
THE RIGHT COURSE FOR THE CHINA
U.S. RELATIONSHIP WE NEED TO
FIND THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR
THE RELATIONSHIP GOING FORWARD
AND ELEVATE THE RELATIONSHIP.
A STATESMAN SHOULD THINK ABOUT
AND KNOW WHERE TO LEAD HIS
COUNTRY.
HE SHOULD ALSO THINK ABOUT AND
KNOW HOW TO GET ALONG WITH
OTHER COUNTRIES AND THE WIDER
WORLD.
IN THIS TIME IN AGE, GREAT
CHANGES ARE UNFOLDING IN WAYS
LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
HUMANITY IS CONFRONTED WITH
UNPRECEDENTED CHALLENGES.
THE WORLD HAS COME TO A
CROSSROADS WHERE TO GO FROM
HERE THIS IS A QUESTION THAT IS
NOT ONLY ON OUR MINDS, BUT ALSO
ON THE MIND OF ALL COUNTRIES.
THE WORLD EXPECTS THAT CHINA
AND THE UNITED STATES WILL
PROPERLY HANDLE THE
RELATIONSHIP AND FOR OUR
MEETING IT HAS ATTRACTED THE
WORLD'S ATTENTION.
SO WE NEED TO WORK WITH MORE
COUNTRIES TO BRING MORE HOPE TO
WORLD PEACE, GREATER CONFIDENCE
TO GLOBAL STABILITY, AND
STRONGER COMMON DEVELOPMENT.
IN OUR MEETING TODAY I AM READY
TO HAVE A CANDID, AS WE ALWAYS
DID HAVE A CANDID EXCHANGE OF
VIEWS WITH YOU ON STRATEGIC
IMPORTANCE IN CHINA'S U.S.
RELATIONSHIPS AND GLOBAL
ISSUES.
I WORK LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU MISTER PRESIDENT, TO
BRING CHINA --
TO THE BENEFIT OF OUR TWO
COUNTRIES AND THE WORLD AS A
WHOLE.
THANK YOU.
>> THE CAMERAS ARE BEING PULLED
AWAY FOR THIS MEETING TO TAKE
PLACE AT THE G20.
BIDEN TALKING ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO KEEP THE
LINES OF COMMUNICATION OPEN AND
BOTH OF THEM BEING QUITE
POSITIVE ABOUT --
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT A
CROSSROADS IN THE RELATIONSHIP,
WHICH BOTH THE WHOLE WORLD IS
LOOKING TO THEM TO NEGOTIATE.
>> THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE AT THE
STAGE, AND THOSE ARE JUST THE
OPENING REMARKS, AND EVEN THAT
UNDERSCORING BOTH OF THEIR
INTENTIONS.
IT UNDERSCORES THE LACK OF
RELATIONSHIP THAT EXISTS, IT
DOES THERE IS SCRAPING THE
BARREL IN OUTLINING THE
CONNECTIONS THEY WOULD HAVE,
THAT THEY CALLED EACH OTHER
WHEN THEY WERE RESPECTIVELY
AFFIRM THEIR HEAD OF STATE.
LET'S BRING INTO IVAN WATSON
AND STEVEN JIANG WHO'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO THAT AS.
WELL I HAVEN'T, WHAT WAS YOUR
31ST THOUGHTS FOR THOSE REMARKS
FROM THE LEADERS?
>> RIGHT, ON A COSMETIC FRONT
YOU HAVE A NOTE THAT EVERYBODY
EXCEPT THE TWO LEADERS ARE MET
WEARING MASKS.
THAT IS A REFLECTION OF CHINA
AND ITS DYNAMIC ZERO COVID
APPROACH.
BIDEN MET WITH THE INDONESIAN
PRESIDENT, THE HOST OF THE G20
SUMMIT EARLIER TODAY, AND THEY
ARE THE TWO DELEGATIONS WERE
NOT WEARING MASKS.
THAT IS ONE DIFFERENCE.
AND WE DID HEAR THAT BIDEN AND,
IMPORTANTLY, SHE JINPING SAYING
THAT THE WORLD IS PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS MEETING.
THE WORLD WANTS SOME KIND OF
MOVEMENT FORWARD AND A DIALOGUE
TO AVOID, BASICALLY BAD THINGS
FROM HAPPENING I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT HE
TALKED ABOUT A CROSSROADS.
IF EUGENE PANG IN FEBRUARY WAS
MEETING WITH A MAN THAT HE
DESCRIBED WITH A CLOSE MAN AS
NO BOUNDARIES, PUTIN, THEY
TALKED ABOUT ESTABLISHING A NEW
WORLD ORDER.
THEY CLEARLY CHASE AT THE
PREEMINENT POSITION OF THE U.S.
HAS HAD SINCE WORLD WAR II.
MEANWHILE, BIDEN IS COMING TO
THIS MEETING TRYING TO
ESTABLISH NEW GUIDELINES AS THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS PUT IT, TO TRY
TO PREVENT A CRISIS FROM
EMERGENCY BETWEEN THE U.S. AND
CHINA.
IT DOES SOUND LIKE THESE TWO
LEADERS ARE TALKING ABOUT SOME
KIND OF NEW FRAMEWORK FOR
INTERACTING WITH EACH OTHER,
RECOGNIZING THAT WHAT HAS BEEN
GOING ON IN THE PAST IS SIMPLY
NOT WORKING.